[Musique]
bonjour merci des prêts pour un nouveau
rendez vous de dimanche en politique nos
élus nous représente t'il vraiment c'est
pour essayer de répondre à cette
question que nous sommes venus ici
aujourd'hui avait narré les laumes
devant la mairie cette petite musique
qu'on entend depuis longtemps c'est elle
s'est mise à résonner très fort depuis
deux mois de novembre depuis le début de
cette crise des gilets jaunes alors
notre système est il vraiment
représentatifs faut-il l'améliorer ou
faut-il tout changer et y aurait-il pour
certains dans ce débat des objectifs
moins désintéressés et plus politique
pour réfléchir à ce sujet nous avons
donné rendez vous à nos invités dans un
lieu symbolique de notre démocratie
une mairie ici à venarey-les-laumes une
mairie ancienne totalement rénové
peut-être une piste où un symbole pour
notre débat du jour qui va donc se
dérouler dans cette salle du conseil
municipal avec le maire de venarey les
laumes patrick molinoz ce bonjour
bonjour vous êtes par ailleurs vice
président prg du conseil régional merci
de nous accueillir ici dans une banque
inauguré par lou de pablo debré pardon
bonjour vous représentez ici le
mouvement majorité silencieuse 21 vous
tenté d'organiser une consultation
citoyenne sur un possible changement des
institutions
une sénatrice avec nos bons jours marie
mercier sénatrice l air de saône et
loire vous avez par ailleurs été
longtemps maire de châtenoy le royal
et puis joël mekhantar bonjour bonjour
vous êtes professeur de droit public il
nous fallait un spécialiste de la
constitution dans ce débat vous êtes par
ailleurs élu dans la majorité municipale
de dijon
notre question du jour finalement je
l'évoquais mais elle est pas elle n'est
pas nouvelle mais pourquoi cette bulle
explose tel maintenant aussi fort
patrick molinoz ce pourquoi d'un seul
coup tout le monde se tourne vraiment
avec acuité sur cette idée de la
représentativité vous posez la question
sous l'angle de la représentativité
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup parce que je
crois d'abord et avant tout en la
démocratie représentative qui doit être
modernisé c'est certain qu'on doit
faire sans doute mieux comprendre à nos
concitoyens mais c'est plutôt un
mouvement m'at-il semblé d'abord
d'interpellation des institutions
peut-être d'interpellations d'une
politique avant d'être un mouvement
l'interpellation sur les fondements de
la démocratie
ce sont d'abord des gens qui ont dit je
crois j'en ai vu beaucoup ici nous ne
sommes pas contents avec telle ou telle
politique la fin dit sf par exemple ou
telle ou telle mesure
cette accumulation de mesures nous
déplaît on veut l'exprimer et puis le
rôle des réseaux sociaux a permis aussi
une mise en lien dans des conditions
nouvelles puisque normalement
traditionnellement le lien entre le
citoyen et la décision publique
c'étaient les luttes proximité avant
qu'ils aient des médias ensuite sont les
médias qui sont venus faire
l'intermédiaire est désormais ya cet
outil de communication directe de
citoyen à citoyen qui fait que tout le
monde peut parler à tout le monde à tout
moment à tout instant sans régulation
sans doute ça a participé au gonflement
de ce mouvement et de cette prise de
confiance qui a des choses à dire
le tableau devrait on est à on est à 1
point maximum de ce questionnement sur
les institutions sur les élus sur leur
représentativité de votre point de vue
on est simplement au tout début de ce
questionnement nous notre association
elle n'entend pas donner une réponse est
ce que les élus sont représentatifs ou
pas de la population par contre vous
vous posez la question quand même la
question elle est posée de manière
suffisamment forte et problématique dans
la société pour qu'on décide d'y trouver
une réponse et en l'occurrence il ya une
partie de la société qui met en
accusation
ces représentants de ne pas faire leur
travail de représentation
donc ici on a des représentants qui
peuvent témoigner comme ça parce qu'un
procès mais au final à la fin va falloir
revenir aux seuls qui vont pouvoir juger
c'est à dire les citoyens et s'ils
doivent juger sans passer par le biais
des représentants faudra passer par le
référendum
bon on va y venir marie mercier comment
vous le comment vous vous lviv
vous aussi en tant qu'élu je disais
aussi vous avez été maire longtemps et
forcément quand on est maire c'est pas
forcément la même chose que quand on est
parlementaire
cette mise en cause en fait de la
représentativité des élus comme angèle
et j comme tous les élus qui sont
dévoués à leur commune à leurs
administrés je le vis pas bien pas bien
on est triste de voir que finalement le
travail ce qu'on a fait en direction de
l'industrie n'est pas forcément bien
compris n'est pas forcément bien et vous
longtemps des vous ai dis bien peut-être
alors les élus où certains élus parce
que ça va être la question ne représente
pas les citoyens comme bien sûr que je
m'entends sauf que nous avons n'avons
pas ces deux fronts nous avons été élus
nos amis seraient nous ont fait
confiance et nous devons être digne de
cette confiance
notre jugement à nous cessons les urnes
sont les scrutins quand on se représente
c'est là où on voit que finalement on a
été bien compris on a bien fait notre
travail parce que de nouveau les
électeurs vont nous choisir pour notre
projet c'est un projet dans certains cas
on sait qu'il ya quand même des
contingences nationale on va dire que je
suis là je pense beaucoup
et bientôt avec gentillesse de le dire
je pense beaucoup aux municipales c'est
un scrutin de proximité et on sait que
le mr reste le référent pour la plupart
de nos concitoyens
j'ai vu votre votre site patrick molinoz
11 mai un mois mais quand on part
d'abord sur cette dimension
constitutionnelle aussi est ce que est
ce qu'il s'est passé ça à d'autres
moments quand il a fallu changer de
constitution est ce qu'on était aussi
dans des crises de représentativité
comme ça sans doute mais il n'y avait
pas la télé à ce moment là quand on
regarde certaines constitutions je
pensais à la constitution de 1793 on
n'invente rien il y avait toute une
procédure qui était prévu dans les
articles 56 et suivant la constitution
de 1793 qui donnait du pouvoir aux
assemblées primaires et quand une
délibération était prise
un délai pourrait pour redonner aux
citoyens la possibilité de se réinvestir
et de se réapproprier la décision donc
cet ancien sais je veux dire c'est à
dire que la partie elle a pas servis
puisque effectivement elle a pas servi
mais nos voisins suisses de proximité
puisque on a une frontière commune
maintenant pratique ça depuis depuis des
années et ça fonctionne très bien on
travaille sur ces questions au centre de
recherche en droit et en sciences
politiques le très dispo à l'université
bourgogne et on a justement on avait
fait ça bien avant les 10 gilet jaune on
a lancé ça avant que c'est un truc qui
s'appelle repenser la constitution un
séminaire de recherche sur ces questions
et on travaille on en faisant tenir
toute une série de l'interlocuteur et
essayer des questions qui sont assez
récurrente
finalement si vous voulez je pense que
ce qui est posée alors y effectivement
la question sociale qui a commencé au
départ de au départ de ceux de ce
mouvement mais il ya aussi la question
institutionnelle qui transparaît dans le
grand débat national et je crois que
derrière je suis je partage un peu ce
que dit patrick money l'eau sur la
représentativité
ceci étant il faut que cette
représentativité elle évolué et qu'elle
aille dans le sens de donner aux
citoyens le moyen de se réapproprier les
questions politiques et techniquement
constitutionnellement c'est possible
simplement il faut arrêter de de
ridicule et de ridiculiser nos voisins
suisses en leur disant ben oui vous
faites du référendum pour les cornes des
vaches vous regardez la réalité il n'ya
pas que les cornes des vaches
voilà oui vous voulez oui je voulais je
voulais réagir parce que vous êtes ici
dans une mairie avec une ancienne maire
un autre élu municipal peut-être
quelqu'un qu'il deviendra un jour je
n'en sais rien le mouvement il l'est au
débat au départ pardon pour contester
l'action d'un exécutif le gouvernement
pas le gouvernement qui n'est pas élu je
vous le rappelle le gouvernement n'est
pas en méditant l'image des élus de
façon globale et les ans des grains de
sa fuite rang sauf si je peux permettre
sauf permettent pour les mères et
pourquoi pour s effrite aussi ça
s'effrite un peut-être même mouvement
mais ça s'effrite quand même beaucoup
moins et pourquoi parce que d'une
manière générale donc presque 36000
communes il ya une relaxe 500 mille
bénévoles quelques élus mais très
minoritaires qui ont quelques uns des
mythes et parce que c'est des questions
qui sont récurrentes dans le débat c'est
sain ce plus de 500 mille élus locaux
ils sont au contact quotidien de la
population certains disent apporter paf
quand il ya un truc qui va pas on
appelle le maire
quand il ya un être qui va on lui dit
parfois mais on a une relation directe
aux problématiques des gens donc dans
ce grand débat du moment il ya une
question qui a été posée à un exécutif
et des réponses qui semble parfois être
déporté sur le dos des élus locaux il
faut qu'on y prête attention on s'est
prêtée naturellement au débat parce que
tu as raison il faut moderniser il faut
ré intéresser les gens mieux leur faire
comprendre comment les choses
fonctionnent mais il faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain
la démocratie sionisme ça veut dire quoi
il faudrait plus de pouvoir à leur
donner plus encore plus de pouvoirs aux
élus locaux n'ont pas forcément moi je
suis l'histoire quand même
institutionnels l'histoire politique de
notre pays de la monarchie à la
république décentralisée
c'est quand même un mouvement continu de
rapprochement de la décision du citoyen
de celui qui décide bien sûr je mange
exagère enfin le roi décide seul puis un
président de la république avec un
parlement qui s'offrent aujourd'hui sauf
qu'on est aussi à des gens qui vous
disent oui mais vous prenez des
décisions que qui nous concerne pas
vraiment comment le souhaitent pendant
la fête telle différence pas vous devrez
entre élu local maire et puis et les
autres ou pas où on l'a fait clairement
d'ailleurs dans notre association la
consultation qu'on est en train
d'essayer d'organiser on essaye de
l'organiser avec l'appui des maires qui
en général sont quand même bien perçue
par une majorité de la population
en fait c'est la question de la majorité
qui doit être retraité c'est à dire que
sur la question essentielle de la loi de
toutes les lois qui est la constitution
de l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
des valeurs cardinales de la société et
des du cadre qui régit le la capacité
des représentants a exercé le pouvoir
sur ça qui est vraiment l'essentiel de
tous
clairement il faut revenir à
l'expression du citoyen pour déterminer
où est la majorité là dessus est-ce
qu'on est d'accord pour conserver les
institutions peu ou prou telles qu'elles
sont est-ce qu'on veut revoir
complètement dans ce cas là il faut une
assemblée constituante
ou est-ce qu'on veut les rendre
légèrement plus participative et dans ce
cas là on peut évoquer le rig madère
voilà le faire un dogme ça va être la
suite de la discussion
marie mercier ancien maire mais vous
êtes parlementaire d'ici on les
parlementaires qui votent alors la
majorité mais les parlementaires qui
votent les lois
c'est eux qui sont aussi dans le bien
sûr bien sûr mais la politique c'est pas
empêché vouloir empêcher les gens de se
mêler de ce qui les regarde les lois
elles viennent de quoi elles viennent
des gens ce sont les gens qui nous
donnent des idées et qui font que nous
avons envie de leur répondre et
d'améliorer les choses la loi elle est
là aussi pour rendre le monde un peu
meilleur
c'est une forme de protection et allez
prenons prenons l'exemple alors c'était
pas la loi mais en partie quand même les
prix du carburant l'augmentation du prix
du carburant qui met le feu décidé à
paris voté à paris nous sommes pas
vraiment on est on est très content nous
les sénateurs parce qu'on avait dénoncé
l'augmentation des carburants nous
l'avions dit ne faites pas cette bêtise
les sénateurs réfléchissent et le
pourquoi la crise elle a pris cette
ampleur c'est une crise du pouvoir
d'achat
au départ c'est le pouvoir d'achat la cg
les retraités qui n'arrivent plus à
subvenir aux normes
le point de départ il est là parce qu'on
a besoin d'argent pour vivre et le point
de départ c'est ça c'est que quand le
travail ne fournit pas assez pour
maintenir une vie décente langis allons
plus loin au delà parce que ça c'est les
discours qu'on entend beaucoup
est-ce que des élus nationaux par
exemple est ce qu'il faudrait que les
élus nationaux soient pauvres pour
comprendre les pauvres qui manifestaient
ce qu'il faudrait c'est ça le
questionnement est est-ce que ça comment
comment vous le dites vous le verriez je
trouve que c'est une façon c'est ça qui
nous inquiète dit aussi dans les
cortèges c'est ça qui est important
il peut y avoir là une forme de
démagogie je veux dire effectivement on
peut avoir plus de transparence et il
faudrait moi je suis partisan par
exemple qu'à chaque élection on indique
on affiche les choses voilà tel telles
élections tels telles quelles
responsabilités telles indemnités
c'est clair et on arrêtera de on se
rendra compte finalement que des jouets
mais ça varie de l'acsa est-ce que ça va
pas au mieux il ya ça il ya cet aspect
critique il ya le financier mais ce qui
n'a pas la dimension sociétale en gros
vous êtes des gens en costume avec des
cravates vous pouvez vaches matin vous
pouvez pas comprendre que nous en gros
il ya sa verrière quand même que
ça c'est quand même pardon c'est ce
qu'on entend depuis plusieurs mois donc
c'est pour ça que je vous la pose aussi
brutalement cette question oui mais à un
moment donné il faut quand même reposer
à mon avis les choses de manière un peu
fondamentale
il n'y a pas décision prise sauf dans
des systèmes totalitaires qui ne soit le
fruit d'une d'une discussion il suffit
pas de hurler chacun qu'on veut bleu
blanc vert pour que d'un seul coup les
choses se réalisent la décision la
décision collective
elle est forcément construite il faut se
parler alors on peut se parler en
cravate on peut se parler sans cravate
il faut des assemblées il faut des gens
qui échangent de manière rationnelle moi
je suis étonné que ça existe il faut ça
existe sauf que le point fondamental et
je veux pas parler à la place de même la
sénatrice mais si les maires et des élus
locaux sont peut-être moins attaquer et
certainement moins mis en cause que
d'autres c'est aussi parce que nous
sommes en liaison directe notre décision
influence directement ce qui se passe le
problème des gouvernements je me penche
stigmatiser un c'est qu'il n'y a
quasiment pas dans la vème république de
contrôle parlementaire efficace
90% des textes de lois adoptées sont des
textes qui sont rédigées par les
ministres ou plus exactement par les
administrations et donc et donc il ya là
sans doute un problème démocratique
majeur n'est pas parce qu'on fait pas
bien il existe aussi un vrai changement
des sourires et des jeunes d'avoir vous
voulez rire
en fait là on est tous des opinions donc
moi je vais éviter d'ailleurs d'en
émettre qui ne soit pas celle de
l'association fait divers mais ce qu'il
faut vous abusez pas aller à quelques
peu importe en fait finalement ce que
vous ce que vous dites vous ce que vous
dites ce sont des témoignages recevable
mais si vous n'acceptez pas un moment
que c'est les citoyens qui vont devoir
donner leurs opinions là dessus et que
comme ce sont les représentants qui sont
mis en cause
ça ne peut pas se faire par leur biais
si vous n'acceptez pas ça on ne trouvera
jamais une réponse satisfaisante calme
modéré construite à la question de la
légitimité du pouvoir actuel
évidemment il faut plus élire il faut
remettre les choses à plat renverser la
table aujourd'hui un système qui est ce
qu'il est il tourne et à l'intérieur les
gens qui ont été élus ils sont légitimes
de faire ce qu'ils ont à faire tel que
c'est décrit dans les textes mais en
parallèle là on a besoin d'une
discussion avec des gens comme vous qui
venez apporter votre expertise votre
témoignage
mais à la fin que ce qui est ce qu'ils
vont trancher c'est les citoyens c'est
peut être la référence et ils le font
tous les six ans dans lemon way mais
tous les six ans il tranche et ils
disent à leurs mères à leurs conseillers
municipaux bien écoutez nous sommes
satisfaits nous ne sommes pas satisfaits
à la présidentielle un certain nombre à
toutes les élections presque on va dire
on va être extrêmes et aux prochaines
européennes
ça se profile a presque plus personne
qui va vous donner c'est donc ce bal ce
n'est pas vrai joli désolé d'y revenir
aux municipales les taux de oui oui il y
en a qui savent on a bien compris au
minimal sauf que ce qui est mis en cause
c'est la politique du gouvernement c'est
des élections législatives dans
lesquelles on avait un accord électoral
qui est extrêmement réduit la gérante la
tête le fait majoritaire c'est oui il ya
la question qui la question est
majoritaire sous la vème 6 1 c'est un
vrai sujet c'est un vrai sujet les gens
ne comprennent pas que certaines forces
avec lesquelles on est d'accord où on
n'est pas d'accord d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'entre elles fin ce qui me
concerne
comment se fait-il qu avec tant de
suffrages on repart présentait donc il
ya la question de la pression que mel b
mais au-delà de ça au delà de la
question du mode de scrutin
effectivement c'est peut-être mieux
d'avoir un petit peu plus de
proportionnelle
encore qu'il faut faire attendre qu'il
fallait faire attention sur le canton
veut faire fonctionner des institutions
il ya deux choses il respect
démocratique et ya l'aspect avoir une
majorité pour pouvoir fonctionner moi je
crois que la vraie question qui est
posée c'est pas tant effectivement il ya
la représentation n'est d'accord le mode
de scrutin il faut toucher cela je crois
que la vraie question c'est surtout de
trouver les moyens constitutionnels les
moyens juridiques qui permettront aux
citoyens le citoyen de ne plus être la
volonté générale sous curatelle mais de
pouvoir se saisir des questions et de
pouvoir les poser moi je suis frappé de
voir quand même quand on regarde le
système suisse
quand quand on est en suisse 2 % du
corps électoral pour une initiative de
révision constitutionnelle peut
enclencher le processus et à la fin
avoir un référendum
enfin
2% même l'initiative européenne a
l'habitude de dire mais c'est un fou
pays c'est facile dans un homme lui non
mais il faut je suis d'accord avec vous
mais il faut c'est des pourcentages donc
les pourcentages regarder chez nous
quand la révision de 2008 prévoit le
référendum d'initiative partagée
oui c'est même pas d'initiative
citoyenne marchait pas même l'union
européenne on critique souvent l'union
européenne quand vous avez une
initiative citoyenne européenne
sept citoyens de cet état différents
peuvent l'a déclenchée alors un million
de signatures on va essayer après tout
c'est chez renault un peu de hauteur je
le mets quand est ce que tout ce qu'on
est en train de se dire là c'est
provoquée par le fait que le citoyen en
général
aujourd'hui il n'est plus le même que le
citoyen on va dire moutons qui suivaient
les partis les syndicats des années 70
des années 80 et qu'il veut influer sur
les choses qu'on plie pas blood devrait
d'abord mais est ce qu'elle est ce que
vous vous avez ce sentiment là et que
c'est pour ça de votre point de vue
qu'il faut changer les choses
aujourd'hui l'émergence par exemple du
risque comme sujet c'est la volonté des
citoyens de se réapproprier le pouvoir
en saisissant eux mêmes par référendum
quand ils ont le sentiment qu'ils sont
plus représentés par les élus et ça
effectivement
jeudi jour jusqu'à redon avec peut-être
un petit bémol c'est que le rics étaient
présents sur les manifestations de gilet
jaune qui représente une parcelle
minuscule du corps électoral français
dont quand vous dites les citoyens on
peut aussi on peut aussi de discuter moi
je ne dis pas que c'est une demande des
citoyens jeudi quand on parle du rics et
sa non pas on parmi eux se réapproprier
la pouvoir c'est une bonne question de
savoir est ce qu'il ya une majorité de
citoyens qui veulent le riquet du coup
pour pouvoir répondre à cette question
mais il faut informer sur quel faux ça
pouvait rire et puis un moment de toute
manière il faudra y répondre et vu que
c'est une volonté de contrôle clairement
des représentants s'est pas
représentants de trancher ce sujet marie
mercier vous vouliez réservé aux enfants
des mères moi vous êtes vous êtes un
simple mais ensuite je voulais rentrer
chez moi j'ai un une difficulté majeure
dans le désamour des citoyens aux
politiques qui
grandi et il faut absolument trouver des
solutions à ça parce qu'on ne peut pas
se satisfaire d'une démocratie qui ne
serait pas diva ce donc il ya un
problème de confiance entre le citoyen
et ses représentants qui doit être
abordées et réglées mais il faut faire
extrêmement attention à ne pas laisser
entendre que par des solutions ultra
simpliste
tout va se régler parce que pour une
partie des gens qui contestent
il ya une partie des gens qui contestent
parce que tout simplement ils ne sont
pas dans la majorité
et ça ça arrive tout le temps de
quelques bords que l'on fournit donc il
faut que vous soyez un an d'avoir rejoué
le match en faisaient déjà qui va
vouloir rejouer le match
il faut donc s'en méfier les partis
politiques ont tendance souvent à
vouloir faire ça encore une fois de
quelque bord qu'ils soient
donc il faut se méfier de ça mais il
faut se méfier encore plus de laisser à
croire aux gens qu'on va leur apporter
décider des solutions ultra simples à
des problèmes qui sont compliquées le
référendum ne peut pas être le mode de
gouvernance personnes de 10 ha autour de
cette table mais ne peut pas être le
mode de gouvernance permanent de toutes
les problématiques qui se posent au
quotidien
sinon on ne fonctionne pas notre
collègue juriste a dit que sur la
proportionnelle il en fallait une dose
il n'est pas poursuivi son propos mais
je sais que ce que l'on pense tous quand
on voit comment ça s'est passé il faut
la proportionnelle mais s'il y en a trop
et si les mécanismes ne sont pas
organisés on arrive à une paralysie de
la décision et s'il n'y a pas de
décisions il n'y a pas d'avancée n'y a
pas d'avancée sociale n'y a pas danger
économique et dont la fessée et à une
question que j'ai envie de poser à marie
mercier parce que elle et au sénat le
sénat c'est une vieille chose qui est
très à la mode en ce moment qui nous
expliquent bien à quel point est
légitime mais c'est une vieille chose
est ce que dans ce cul dans ce qu'il
faut faire de la cosmétique et ce qu'il
faut mettre un peu de proportionnelle
reconnaître le vote blanc ou est ce
qu'il faut ce que prônée par certains
une assemblée constituante aller très
loin tout revoir de votre point de vue
vous qui siégeait dans une vieille dans
une vieille institution chambre et et
nous portons le poids de l'histoire
aussi qui est important pour savoir où
on dit souvent que vous ne servez à rien
davantage quel est le travail cat le
faire ben alors
alors il se trouve que je siéger à la
commission des lois donc je suis ville
enquête pénale à l'essentiel de mon
travail actuellement c'est la prévention
de l'enfance et la prévention des
violences sexuelles sur mineures je
passe beaucoup de temps au temps ça mais
quand nous fabriquons une loi qu'elle
arrive au sénat il ya plus de 63% des
amendements des sénateurs qui sont
repris par l'assemblée nationale quelle
que soit la couleur du sénat ou de
l'assemblée nationale parce que nous
sommes là pour aller un petit peu plus
loin vous avez dit mon cher collègue
l'essentiel c'était de se parler c'est
surtout de s'écouter ce qui serait bien
c'est que notre président le gouvernant
ils écoutés ils entendent ce qu'on veut
lui dire le succès le succès des gilet
jaune ça a été plus qu'un soutien pour
moi c'est une forme d'identification
on fait tous reconnus tout le monde on
avait un petit gilet jaune quelque part
même quand on était des élus alors
s'écouter c'est bien très bien quand on
va proposer un référendum
quelle va être la question et ensuite
quel va être le but de ce référendum
comment on va derrière le replace les
choses déjà mais parce que il faut
donner des réponses et que le but ce
n'est pas de tout mettre par terre il
faut souligner cet effort de la question
c'est est ce qu'on regarde ce qu'on a
c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait ça je crois
qu'il faut garder des fondamentaux c'est
quand c'est pas d'aujourd'hui il faut
garder un socle vous savez moi mon
métier ses médecins et on n'a jamais su
soigner la maladie peut alors vous vous
travaillez à faire voter des lois si on
met en place un rite dans lequel on peut
par exemple revenir sur une loi qui a
été votée voilà imaginons qu'ils soient
comme ça rick qui pourraient abrogatoire
vous vous accepteriez vous
parlementaires représentant d'une
légitimité que derrière une autre partie
de là mais tout à fait j'ai dû dire
qu'il y a des lois scélérates
il y a des lois scélérates je n'étais
pas celle de votre camp femmes n'ont pas
du tout pas du tout j'irai une commune
en 17 ans avec la loi sur le non-cumul
des mandats je suis sénateur je
représente les territoires on ne pourra
plus actuellement être maire et sénateur
on ne peut plus je trouve que c'est
quelque chose qui c'est une distance pas
plus le parent est le passeur c'est là
dessus que les citoyens vont lancer avec
quand même
lsi dommage vraiment là-dessus sur le il
nous reste trois mieux démission ça
passe affreusement bien le riz qu on
parle de par voie de rick abrogatoire
voir de riches révocatoire estia
quand vous en parler autour de vous vous
demanderez pas de prendre parti si on a
bien compris que vous organisez cette
chose là mais quand vous en parler
autour de vous la tendance c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui veulent quelque chose
d'extrême ou des gens qui veulent juste
qu'on les écoute dans les contacts que
vous avez du tout pour un moment on a
fait des réunions qui pouvait être entre
40 et 80 sur l'écriture le débat sur les
textes
là tout le monde quand ils essayent les
jambes de sapri s'approprier le riquet
par exemple de où l'assemblée
constituante est de 10 rebonds qu'est-ce
qu'on va qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait mettre dedans
tout le monde a l'ambition de faire
quelque chose de stable et de
constructif d'accord voilà de toute
manière il ya seihai no prime l'intérêt
général alors après l'intérêt général
peut-être et la volonté générale
peut-être de conserver les institutions
telles qu'elles sont mais ça il faut le
vérifier ces importantes de tester c'est
important aussi pour vous les élus parce
qu'une fois que vous connaîtrez là
vraiment la volonté générale vous
pourrez l'appliquer et sereinement
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans cette
récusation compliqué chaque candidat à
la présidence de la république on sait
ne veut jamais mettre en cause le
système puisque ça mettrait en cause sa
propre présidence
je sais que ça a été comme ça à chaque
fois je pense que la révision qui est
qui est en stand en attente on va dire
pour l'instant avait un petit peu tenté
d'anticiper avec une une chambre de la
société civile anac un droit de pétition
etc
sauf que on n'est plus là on n'en est
plus là aujourd'hui compte tenu du
mouvement des gilet jaune est en fait je
crois que ce qui était important aussi à
dire par rapport à ce mouvement c'est
qu'on a retrouvé le troisième terme de
la devise républicaine c'est la
fraternité la fraternité elle s'est
exprimée sur les sur les ronds-points ou
les gens qui se connaissaient pas ont
pris le café ensemble maintenant je suis
sûr qu'il y aura des gens qui seront
amis de de se serrer les dents en même
temps mes nerfs lendemain d'une
manifestation qui a été marqué par très
grande violence à paris aussi oui on a
beaucoup insisté sur les violences dans
l'est samedi mais il n'y avait pas que
les gens qui étaient là à chaque samedi
chacun qu'il y aurait une minute trente
alors moi j'ai envie de vous poser la
question est ce que vous souhaitez vous
qui est un référendum
bientôt on parle beaucoup d'un
référendum qcm qui pose un certain
nombre de questions est ce qui vous
semble qu'il faut comme le disait pablo
debré qui est un référendum il compose
la question français sur mon mail rick
on revoit la constitution est ce que ça
vous semble une bonne idée ou pas en
tant que les élus mmes
m'importe là dessus très vite patrick je
pense que pour réconcilier les citoyens
avec la politique il faut toujours
toujours toujours travaillé à réduire
l'écart entre la promesse électorale et
sa réalisation le vrai problème il est
là
des élus qui promet beaucoup qui réalise
que le référendum est rarement une bonne
méthode parce que très souvent très
souvent la réponse apportée n'est pas
celle qui correspond à la question posée
et pestant il faut trouver le moyen de
moderniser et dunkerque où j'allais plus
loin je suis obligé de vous couper parce
que c'est papa notre émission je sais ça
aurait pu durer beaucoup plus longtemps
c'est un sujet complexe mais qui va se
poursuivre dans les prochains jours avec
la restitution des grands débats et
peut-être un référendum
merci à tous les cas d'être venu ici
avec narrer les laumes merci nous avoir
accueillis et bon dimanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]